Android P Developer Preview too is here
providing a significantly updated
snapshot of what the next release of
Android is ultimately going to bring to
developers slices allow you to surface
rich templated UI from your app in
places like Google search and assistant
they can be interactive as well with
support for actions toggles sliders and
more slices are part of jetpack which
means they are backwards compatible and
fully updatable including new template
types app actions are closely related to
slices slices essentially provide a UI
for embedded app functionality while
actions are a new way if your app to
provide a list of intents to expose
functionality within Google assistant
with possibilities such as watching a
video reading a book hailing a ride and
more Android is adding notification
animations to allow for seamless
transitions from notification to app you
don't have to do anything to take
advantage of this feature but it will be
so much better if you make your app
start quickly particularly when cold
starting typing a reply from within a
notification is great but not having to
type at all is even better Smart replies
allow you to present quick choices that
can be acted upon right in the
notification text measurement is
expensive which is why the new
precomputed text API can offload a large
chunk of this work to a worker thread
precomputed text does require more
memory per glyph but in many cases this
trade-off will be well worth it Android
is also adding a new magnifier widget
designed for improved text selection and
cursor manipulation by default classes
that extend texture you automatically
support the magnifier but you can use
the magnifier API to attach it to any
custom view which opens it up to a
variety of uses there are new api's to
make your app more accessible
accessibility pane titles allow
accessibility services to determine when
specific sections of the screen have
updated which is particularly helpful
for supporting fragment transitions you
can specify a title for a pain such as
the content area of a fragment with the
Android colon accessibility pane title
attribute or change it at runtime with
set accessibility pane title similarly
you can now identify text views as being
headers which allows talkback the
the gate between them previously the
attribute for focusable could be used
either to optimize your app or keyboard
accessibility or for talkback
accessibility we've now added is screen
reader focusable so you can make sure
that your app navigates optimally for
both keyboards and screen readers
in display cutouts we've made a few
minor API changes since the first
preview namely layout in display cutout
mode always has become short edges to
reflect that P only supports cutouts on
the short edges since the API supports
cutouts on both edges simultaneously now
you get a list of all cutout bounding
recs instead of a single bounce we now
have a theme attribute to tell Android
to layout your activity in the cutout
area this attribute will also be
available on some Android o devices that
have cutouts so it's a backwards
compatible way to declare that your app
can utilize the cutout area also the
developer options now support emulation
of more cutout types such as corner and
top bottom dual cutout Android is
continuing to invest to improve battery
life and system health apps stand by
bucket puts running apps into groups
with different restrictions based upon
usage patterns apps will change buckets
over time and apps not in the active
bucket will have additional restrictions
around jobs alarms Network and high
priority firebase cloud messages as a
developer you can test how your app
operates under each of four defined
buckets using adb commands check out the
documentation on app standby buckets for
details from our work on android vitals
and where it can detect battery draining
app behaviors within battery settings
Android will flying the list of these
apps and let the user apply restrictions
to the apps background activities you
can manually apply background
restrictions via ADB to test how your
app behaves and performs you can use
activity manager is background
restricted to determine at runtime if
background restrictions have been
applied biometric prompt was added to
Developer Preview too replacing the
fingerprint dialog from dp1 in addition
to supporting fingerprints including and
display sensors it supports face and
iris authentication providing a
system-wide consistent experience
there is a single-use biometrics
permission that covers all device
supported biometrics fingerprint manager
and the corresponding used fingerprint
permission are deprecated so please
switch to biometric prompt as soon as
possible we've added strongbox as a new
key store back-end providing API support
for devices that provide key storage and
tamper resistant hardware with isolated
CPU RAM and flash you can set whether
your key should be protected by a
strongbox security chip in your key gen
parameter spec autofill has added an API
that allows it to work well inside of
recyclerview getnext autofill ID is used
to manage views whose content is
recycled it returns an ID that is unique
in the activity which you can associate
with every item in your adapter as they
are initially viewed you can then call
set autofill ID on each view as it is
reused in the first preview we displayed
a toast warning when it hath used a non
SDK interface that we plan to restrict
but in the second preview we are
enforcing these restrictions which means
it will get exceptions thrown or nulls
return instead of a warning if the non
SDK interface is required for your app
to function and there aren't SDK
alternatives please file an issue with
us immediately also strict mode now
supports a warning when it detects
reflective usage of api's that aren't
part of the public Android SDK even if
they still work in the preview so you
can plan for the future and eliminate
non SDK API use the preview includes
Vulcan 1.1 a substantial update to the
industry standard cross platform
graphics and compute API and here are
some highlights multi-view is great for
VR allowing efficient generation of left
and right eye views external memory and
ycbcr formats enable processing of video
and camera images while a collection of
additional shader capabilities improve
compatibility with shaders written in
HLSL and open CLC thanks to the support
of device manufacturers in the work we
did in Oreo with project trouble to
enable faster system upgrades you can
test the preview on more devices than
ever before including devices from
manufacturers such as Yowie Sony
essential vivo Oppo Nokia and others
also developer preview 2
is available through Android beta on
pixel and pixel to series devices so
consumers can try it out as well as
always your feedback is critical so
please let us know what you think the
sooner we hear from you the more of your
feedback we can integrate look in the
video description for details on how to
report issues and enjoy Developer
Preview too
[Music]